[Music]
2019 has seen the loss of a myriad of
hugely talented actors with a range of
different backgrounds
from movies to television to the
broadway stage
but while they may have made their names
in different worlds
they are all connected by a true
dedication to their craft
and by the many fans who will miss them
dearly
three years after the death of r2d2
actor kenny baker the man who brought
chewbacca to life in the original star
wars trilogy
also passed away in a statement the
family of peter mayhew confirmed that
the towering actor died at his texas
home on april 30th 2019.
the statement celebrated mayhew's life
focusing on the experiences and lifelong
friendships that came from his time as
part of the star wars family
it read as the films released and became
more well known
he had his eyes opened to the
possibilities of what he could achieve
for more than 30 years peter traveled
all over the world
spending time with his fans and friends
laugh it up fuzzball but mayhew did a
lot more than just the convention
circuit
over the years he became heavily
involved with the 501st legion
wounded warriors make-a-wish and other
non-profit organizations
in a tribute tweet mayhew's star wars
co-star mark hamill wrote
he was the gentlest of giants a big man
with an even bigger heart who never
failed to make me smile
and a loyal friend who i loved dearly
i'm grateful for the memories we shared
and i'm a better man for just having
known him thanks pete
against all odds the previously
wheelchair-bound mayhew returned to play
chewbacca in 2015's the force awakens
his final on-screen appearance as the
iconic wookie
he is survived by his wife angie mayhew
and their three children
he may have just been 20 when he passed
away in his sleep following a seizure
but according to disney cameron boyce
was quote already a veteran to show
business
the actor played the mischievous luke
ross in almost 100 episodes of the
disney series
jesse and later portrayed carlos deville
in the descendants franchise
voice also popped up in a number of more
adult-oriented projects
he was in k-horror remake mirrors and
also appeared in the adam sandler comedy
grown-ups as well as its 2012 sequel
voice's final project was mrs fletcher
an hbo comedy series that's due for
release in fall
2019. on behalf of boyce's family a
disney channel spokesperson told cnn
from a young age cameron boyce dreamed
of sharing his extraordinary artistic
talents with the world
he was an incredibly talented performer
a remarkably caring and thoughtful
person
and above all else he was a loving and
dedicated
son brother grandson and friend we offer
our deepest condolences to his family
castmates and colleagues and join his
many millions of fans in grieving his
untimely passing
he will be dearly missed those who knew
boys professionally took to social media
to share their shock and grief
adam sandler wrote too young too sweet
too funny just the nicest most talented
and most decent kid around
loved that kid though he played founding
mib member zed
in 1997's men in black and dozens of
other roles
riptorn will always be remembered as
artie from the larry sanders show
after torn's passing in july 2019
variety wrote the emmy-winning
performance was perhaps the best
representation of torn's unusual blend
of toughness and tender sentimentality a
turn that was as often profane
as it was unexpectedly moving torn was
nominated for an emmy for every single
season in which he appeared on the larry
sanders show
and he got another nod in 2008 after a
memorable guest appearance on 30 rock
playing jack donaghy's high-flying boss
don geiss oh hair like a viking god
bless you
his work on the big screen was lauded
too with the multi-talented torn
nominated for an oscar and the best
supporting actor category after
portraying mary steenbergen's shotgun
happy father in 1984's cross creek
according to his publicist the
texas-born actor passed away peacefully
at his home in connecticut
he was 88. best known to international
audiences for his engrossing performance
as blade runner antagonist roy batty
rutgerhauer passed away in july 2019
after a short illness
he was 75. blade runner was howard's
second american movie
though he was already a veteran in the
netherlands by that point
the towering dutchman entered the
industry after serving in the military
striking up a fruitful working
relationship with his fellow dutchman
paul verhoeven the auteur cast him in
the eponymous role for his tv series
flores
and they would later work together on
period drama katie tipple
world war ii epic soldier of orange and
art house drama spatters
and while 1982's blade runner was a
critical flop upon release
the movie soon went on to become a cult
classic power's tears in rain monologue
which he wrote himself
is now considered an iconic moment in
the history of cinema and a perfect
example of his gentle giant nature
all those moments
will be lost in time
after howar's passing blade runner
director ridley scott said
i don't know who was more nervous on
that first morning of the first day on
set
we helped each other through the entire
process because it was very challenging
i'll miss him power became a prolific
character actor in the years that
followed
popping up in sin city batman begins
true blood
and countless genre films he is survived
by his wife of 50 years
and his daughter actress and former
model peggy lipton who first made a name
for herself in the late 60s playing
hippie cop julie barnes on the mod squad
passed away from cancer in may 2019
in a statement lipton's daughters parks
and recreation actress rashida jones and
her sister kadada
said that their mother passed away
surrounded by family at the age of 72.
the statement read she made her journey
peacefully with her daughters and nieces
by her side
we feel so lucky for every moment we
spent with her
we can't put all of our feelings into
words right now but we will say
peggy was and will always be our beacon
of light both in this world and beyond
despite winning a golden globe for her
work on the mod squad lipton once took a
long break from acting
sitting out most of the 80s she appeared
back on the scene in 1990 however when
she appeared as norma jennings in david
lynch's surreal tv series twin peaks
speaking to the georgian journal in 2017
the year she reprised the role on the
show's critically acclaimed comeback
lipton recalled her first meeting with
lynch she said
i arrived and he and mark frost his
co-writer and producer
sat at a large table with nothing on it
but my photo
i shot the pilot and the feeling inside
me was pure excitement
i loved being norma maine born actress
stephanie nisnick
passed away unexpectedly in california
on june 23
2019 at the age of 52. nisnik majored in
russian and theater
and would go on to hone her acting
skills at the california institute of
the arts
after graduating from cal arts she
landed a part in the dan aykroyd lead
comedy exit to eden her feature film
debut
niznik became a tv regular in the years
that followed and is perhaps best known
for her time on the wb show
everwood in which she portrayed caring
next-door neighbor nina feeney
in a joint statement after her passing
everwoods creators said
she continued that role off-screen by
being an incredible friend
a nurturing mother figure to our
youngest cast members and
an artist who brought warmth compassion
and humor
to every episode and are set everyone
who is lucky enough to know and work
with her will miss her dearly
nizink was also well known to star trek
fans she played trill starfleet ensign
calparum
in the 1998 feature film star trek
insurrection
she also later popped up in the star
trek enterprise tv series
appearing as a humanoid wraith in the
season 1 episode
rogue planet famed new york socialite
and two-time
oscar nominee sylvia miles passed away
in june
2019 she was 94. speaking to page six
actress geraldine smith revealed that
miles had recently moved out of a care
home
smith a long time friend of miles said
she didn't want to die there we went out
for a big lunch to celebrate her coming
home
she was very excited and telling us to
order whatever we wanted
order drinks order desserts we had a
wonderful time
miles was well known for being the life
of the party and was frequently spotted
at swanky social events with fellow new
york resident andy warhol
speaking to people in 1976 miles
revealed that she was always on the
guest list for the top shindigs because
she knew how to have a good time
she explained i get invited because i'm
fun i have a good sense of humor
i look good i'm not bad to have at a
party one of her most
notable films 1972's heat was produced
by warhol
but miles will no doubt be best
remembered for her sassy turns in 1969's
midnight cowboy
and 1975's farewell my lovely
amazingly she was nominated in the best
supporting actress category for both
movies despite only being on screen for
a combined total of 11 minutes
manhattan-born railroad heiress gloria
vanderbilt passed away at her new york
home in june 2019
having recently been diagnosed with an
advanced form of stomach cancer
she was 95. vanderbilt began her acting
career in 1957
but she was already well known by the
time she made her debut
she was just 10 years old when she
became the subject of a high-profile
court battle between her widowed mother
gloria morgan vanderbilt and her
paternal aunt gertrude vanderbilt
whitney
both of whom saw custody of her and
control over her trust fund
after that vanderbilt set out to prove
she was more than the poor little rich
girl portrayed by the newspaper
headlines
she landed roles on several golden era
anthology shows during the late 50s and
early 60s
quickly establishing herself as an
actress she also appeared in adventures
in paradise
an exotic abc show about a korean war
vet living in the pacific
and the love boat a cruise ship set
comedy that ran from 1977 to 1987.
she was known for much more than her
acting however becoming particularly
known as a fashion designer
her son anderson cooper was keen to
highlight this in his statement after
her passing
he said gloria vanderbilt was an
extraordinary woman who loved life
and lived it on her own terms she was a
painter a writer and designer
but also a remarkable mother wife and
friend
canadian actress stephanie shirk wife of
oscar nominee
demi and beshear passed away peacefully
in april 2019.
the actor confirmed his wife's death in
a heartbreaking instagram post
calling it the saddest and toughest time
of his life he wrote
we don't know how much time it will take
for us to overcome this pain
stephanie's beautiful angelical and
talented presence will be immensely
missed
the cause of death was soon confirmed as
suicide
after the los angeles county medical
examiner coroner made the information
public
beshear went into more detail about the
invisible affliction that shirk had been
dealing with
in a second instagram post that has
since been deleted he wrote it was our
hope that we would have some time to
heal and grieve before we could talk
about this
issue that affects way too many people
around the globe
depression has taken the lives of so
many beautiful wonderful
talented people such as my beloved wife
stephanie
sadly these aren't the only actors who
have left us in 2019
here are some of the other stars who
enhanced our lives before leaving us all
too soon
russy taylor
carmine kiriti
genevieve waite
[Music]
barbara perry
if you or anyone you know is having
suicidal thoughts please call the
national suicide prevention lifeline
at two seven 1-800-273 talk eight two
five five